the one thing i don't understand is
why are people always surprised when
there's a shark in the ocean like
you're throwing dead animals into the
ocean what did you think was gonna pop
up flipper
hey gq i'm melissa christina marquez and
i'm a marine biologist
this is the breakdown
[Music]
first up jaws so jaws is probably one of
my favorite shark movies hands down
while it didn't inspire me to become a
shark scientist it definitely piqued my
interest in what these animals were all
about
all right so you see that that's called
counter camouflage so that's when a
shark
has two different colors it's usually
darker on top and lighter on the bottom
and it's
just for these kind of purposes where
it's really hard to see the shark even
though the water is pretty clear
and it's not that far away it's an
amazing tactic that they use
for stealth and being able to surprise
attack a prey
if you look at a shark from above and
you're looking down
the darker skin color actually blends
into the ocean water
and the ocean ground whereas if you're
looking up at a shark from when you're
beneath it
the white belly actually kind of looks
like sunlight trickling down
so what you just saw is actually
something really common in shark science
which means the shark leaves a lot of
time we want the shark to come right
at us and usually it leaves but these
cages
are perfect for not only seeing sharks
underwater but actually tagging them
with something that lets us actually
know
more about its lifestyle so where it's
been where it's going
what it's doing what it's eating at what
temperature or light depth it's at
so a lot of times we actually have a
similar pull
to what you saw here with kind of like a
dart at the end of it
and at that dart we actually attach a
tag to it and
embed it in what's that dorsal fin so
that top fin
for the shark you try to embed it in
there because that's probably one of the
toughest areas
to get rid of a tag so it doesn't hurt
the shark
it kind of feels like a bit of a pinch
very similar to what you saw you kind of
hold on to the edges of the bar
kind of wait for the shark to come by
and you kind of just stab
at the shark and hope it sticks
otherwise that's thousands of dollars
that have just sunk to the
bottom of the ocean we don't ever inject
our sharks with poison it probably
wouldn't work they have quite high
immune systems
they're not impenetrable but i've never
heard of anyone
successfully trying or wanting to try to
poison a shark through a dart method
i love the iconic jaws music the
build-up of the music is amazing because
you're just kind of sitting there in
suspense being like right
when's it gonna happen when's it gonna
happen when's the ah there's the big boy
[Music]
in jaws bruce which is the main
character
is a great white shark while sharks
sometimes can
ram a cage especially if the bait is
being pulled really really close
to the cage unlike a lot of fish shark
actually can't swim backwards so once
they're going somewhere they really have
not much wiggle room to be able to
backtrack
so a lot of times if the bait is being
pulled too close to the cage or the
shark itself gets too close to the cage
it can't go backwards and it has to ram
into the cage
personally for me i haven't had any bad
cage experiences i have had sharks
actually ram the cage
will it make a dent like this no
i'd have to be a really really big shark
and so far from all of the experiences
that i've had
and that i've seen no shark can
do that much damage to a cage most of
the shark cages that you see nowadays
actually have the same exact structure
as the cages back in the 70s and the 80s
so even back then a shark wouldn't be
able to
make such a big dent in it
so that is probably one of my favorite
parts of the entire movie just because
you can see how
fake bruce looks um but i mean it wasn't
bad for way back when when they kind of
made all the animatronics for this
[Music]
a few times i have seen a shark actually
enter a cage it's usually a smaller
shirt that's actually gone in between
the bars by accident
and it does not like it whatsoever
it's actually most of the time pretty
terrified
the ending of this clip is actually real
sharks on top of
a shark diving cage it does happen they
usually do freak out and as you can kind
of see there's a lot of thrashing as
they're trying to get back into their
natural environment back into the ocean
so the reason why he dove all the way
down to the bottom of the ocean floor is
because sharks are what we call ambush
predators so they like attacking
something at the surface whereas
something
on the actual ground can see where a
shark is coming kind of wedged
themselves
into a place of safety so it's not so
much that sharks can't go that deep
it's a lot harder for them to actually
be with a surprise attack
which is their preferred mode of hunting
jaws actually helped kind of have a
catalyst of not only people who were
interested in sharks but also people who
were
absolutely terrified of sharks the
author
peter eventually actually regrets
writing it and spent a lot of his time
doing ocean conservation and trying to
right the wrong of making sharks not be
as
vilified but unfortunately a lot of
people still do cite this movie
as one reason as to why they are so
afraid of sharks and the ocean
next up we've got the meg
megalodon is a very very very extinct
shark uh contrary to what some things
might say out there it is no longer in
our oceans unfortunately but it was a
giant
shark that a lot of people have likened
to look like a great white shark
even though it is actually more closely
related to other sharks such as mako
sharks
there's quite a few theories that have
gone around as to why it became
extinct everything from climate change
to a giant meteor
that their prey item ran out so it's
really really interesting to kind of see
what ended up happening with this big
shark but there is a giant fascination
with this giant predator
well we don't know if megalodon would
actually go through kelp forest it's
actually just been recently found out
that great white sharks which are
a relative of the megalodon
shark actually does go through kelp
forest previously a lot of
shark scientists we all believe that
sharks kind of
didn't like that barrier and stayed away
from it but
new technology such as a gopro attached
to the top fin of a shark
has actually showed that they do haunt
through a kelp forest
so nowhere is safe
oh thousands of dollars right to the
ground
i promise you no shark is big enough to
get an
anchor stuck to it and be able to pull
multiple people
and other giant structures with it but
it's pretty cool to see
in cgi
if an anchor got stuck on a shark this
shark would probably die
at least nowadays unless it was like a
whale shark or something which is one of
the bigger sharks that are out there now
so there's a myth around sharks that all
sharks need to constantly keep swimming
in order to breathe
that's not true actually for every
single species of shark
there are some sharks that can actually
lay down on the ground
and open and close their mouths in
something that's called ram ventilation
and force water to come
into their mouths out of their gills and
have the gills actually extract the
oxygen that way
and so for some sharks like a great
white or a megalodon you would have to
consistently
keep swimming in order to breathe and to
live
i'm very surprised that nobody realizes
there's a giant mass swimming underneath
[Music]
them
so this is what you don't want to do
when someone screams shark and that's
splash about and cause a lot of chaos
one of the
big rules that we have in order to swim
safely
in the ocean is to always swim with a
body and so you want to have a buddy
with you to be able to look around make
sure
you know if there is a shark keep an eye
on it but you also want to make sure
that you don't cause more attention on
yourself
and that means a lot of splashing at the
top a lot of erratic swimming
because that to a shark actually sounds
like something that a wounded fish or
wounded animal would actually do
so if you're trying to get away from a
shark try to have
control of your swimming and always
remember it's not the shark that you see
that's
sometimes the problems it's sometimes
the one you don't see
how do they lose such a big shark
there you go
so in modern history the largest shark
that has ever been recorded
is probably a whale shark they get up to
40 feet long or about like 12 meters
would a shark ever approach that many
people depends on how timid the shark is
there are some species of sharks that
are quite shy
for example hammerhead sharks don't like
bubbles that scuba divers
give off and you usually have to like
hold your breath or be on something
that's called a rebreather that doesn't
put out bubbles in order to swim with
hammerhead sharks but i don't think
a shark would actually go around and be
around that many people
unless it knew that there was food
around and it was really really hungry
china does have sharks asia in general
does have sharks
was megalodon one of them we don't know
it's full range
but i don't believe we found any
megalodon teeth or other fossils
to indicate that it has been in that
area in central america
they found what they believe was
actually a megalodon nursery
ground which is another reason as to why
people were like megalodon is 100
extinct
because it's nursery is above the water
now
shark ages very very very wildly so
anywhere
from 10 20 years to if you're a
greenland shark you've been around for
400 plus years
for megalodon shark we're not 100 sure
though
what its life expectancy was
what we've just seen with them lowering
the machine and the
i'm assuming it kind of looks like a
hydrophone which emits like
the dolphin noise and the whale noise
that's not something that happens i've
never heard of anyone using that as a
shark repellent
or as a shark deterrent dolphins and
whales
actually eat the same exact stuff as
sharks so if those animals are round
usually a shark's around too there have
been reports of dolphins and whales
head butting and driving away sharks but
don't always count on it
next up we've got lara croft tomb raider
cradle of life
[Music]
that was very quick all right so what
she just did
is cut herself in order to attract a
shark to come closer to her
usually it doesn't happen this
instantaneously
and to be honest if you cut yourself in
real life
chances of you attracting a shark are
actually very very slim
you have a bigger chance of probably
contracting an infection in the water
than you are of attracting
a shark but anything from a minute
amount might be able to kind of pick up
their senses and perk their senses and
be like oh
something's bleeding i should probably
go check it out and eat it
this one kind of seems to be like a
tiger shark but without the stripes
so i'm not the biggest fan of it because
it's without the stripes
you know that noise that the shark made
that hiss noise sharks don't make noises
like that they actually don't make
noises
at all really except if you're some
species of sharks
like dog sharks you take them out of the
water and they're known to
bark as they release air out
that sounded more cat-like than
shark-like
yeah that's a great way of deterring a
shark but have you ever tried punching
something underwater before
you're usually quite slow there's a bit
of drag whereas sharks they're
literally built to not have drag they're
covered in something that's called
dermal denticles and
it actually kind of makes them quite
hydrodynamic i probably wouldn't punch a
shark
in the snout just because your hand
might actually end up down its throat
instead try to aim for the eyes or even
better
aim for those gill slits on the side
that's where it breathes
basically it's almost as if you were
sucker punching someone in the lungs
it's gonna take their breath away
they're not gonna like it they're
probably gonna go away the shirt teeth
aren't
exactly the best um it doesn't look
completely realistic especially how the
the shark kind of like almost yawns in a
way
after laura has punched it in the mouth
and it kind of
shakes his head and goes away yeah
sharks will shake their head and kind of
go away but the whole yawning bit isn't
as often seen in sharks
some species yeah tiger sharks not as
much
so it's a really good thing that she has
gloves on i don't know if you guys have
ever felt a shark but how many of you
guys have felt
sandpaper very similar and it hurts
when you rub up against it and that's
the same exact thing with
sharks so if you rub up the wrong way we
actually have a term for this in shark
science called
shark burn those fingers yeah are
definitely going to be feeling the burn
quite literally also don't do this
please don't ride sharks it's
so so bad for them
not only are you stressing the animal
out but it could turn around and bite
you and
that's not good for you
is it realistic that laura croft held
her breath for so long
yes it's actually something that's
called freediving and it's quite common
a lot of people can actually dive to
deep deaths in the ocean
without taking a single breath quite
advanced level skills
and it's something that i really wish i
had but my lungs suck so i can't
one of the things that i love personally
about tiger sharks on top of everything
else because they're my favorite shark
is the nickname that they have of trash
cans of the sea
and that's because they're pretty and
discriminatory of what they eat
everything from chicken wire tnt
suits of armor tires license plates they
really don't care and aren't that picky
next up couples retreat and you're too
busy complaining about your problems to
enjoy all these beautiful little fish
i wish there was an experience like this
where you could float by something and
just
feed fish but it doesn't exist because
it's dangerous as hell
sure what jason okay it's all happening
the one thing i don't understand is why
are people always surprised when there's
a shark in the ocean like
if the sharks showed up in your bathtub
sure have this reaction but like
you're throwing dead animals into the
ocean what did you think was gonna pop
up flipper
well if life is circling our lives right
now do not move do not panic
move but gently and without panic marcel
i need you to take the french out of
your mouth and tell me what to do
don't let them see your fear don't let
him see your fear that's very good
advice
because sharks can actually detect your
heart rate going up
so do try to stay calm don't worry
these are only lemon sharks this is all
part of the core
so supposedly these are lemon sharks but
they don't look like lemon sharks to me
it actually looks more like some sort of
reef shark the size of the shark for
those smaller reef sharks is
pretty accurate if not maybe a little
bit on the smaller size
don't do that don't don't spill chub on
your mate don't do that
for those who don't know chumming
essentially is what we kind of just saw
of just having a bucket full of
blood fish cuts and oil and bits of fish
that you
kind of like take out one by one and
kind of get it in a nice
soupy mixture to attract sharks to come
closer to you
it's not something that we tell people
to do but also scientists do use it for
scientific research purposes
such as tagging a shark or doing a fin
id what he should probably do is get out
of the blood
let's get out of the champ but slowly
swim slowly out the chance
that is very good i like him i like this
french dude he is giving good advice
get out of the chum slowly don't panic
they're torturing me they're playing
with me they're slow playing me
shut up slowly that is not staying calm
that's panicking
the stop and start tactic i don't really
know if it would help her
hurt because if the shark wants to go at
you it doesn't matter if you stop
it's gonna know you're there it's not
gonna be like oh it's stopped moving i
don't know where it went
all of a sudden like it knows you're
there
go to shore it's too late
hey it's only a matter of time
there's no no sharks around you honey if
you notice on that last bit where he's
kind of far away from
the sharks all of them are just in that
one bucket and that's all that they were
really curious about was the blood would
that happen in real life
possibly word of advice is just don't
have a bucket of chums
slammed on top of you because you don't
want to take any chances
next up we've got 47 meters down uncaged
all right so a few things right off the
bat they're supposed to be in fresh
water and there are some shark species
that are in fresh water
they don't look like this or get that
big
and it seems like the shark is all
supposed to be blind that's why it's got
that milky covering over its eyes
we haven't really seen that in many
shark species either the only sharks
that i've ever seen that are partially
blind are actually greenland sharks when
they have these little parasites or
copepods
off of their eyes and it does kind of
give them like a milky look but
definitely not like that so far seems
pretty unrealistic but from what i'm
seeing it looks like it has five
gill slits so that's anatomically
correct
are there a lot of sharks that are in
caves not that i've heard of
a couple of years ago it actually made
international news that there were some
sharks that were found in like an
underwater volcano even though it's
very unrealistic that there's this many
sharks let alone in a cave area
who does maybe we just haven't
discovered any yet
[Music]
the shark doesn't really look like any
shark to me
it seems like someone took a bunch of
like different pieces of sharks and made
it into this like zombie looking shark
it almost looks like
a makeup or a poor beagle shark but
that's just like their little face and
their body feature looks
like that
you wouldn't really be able to see a
shark coming towards you if it's coming
from underneath
um depending i guess on the life jacket
if you've got a really puffy one
you're lucky to see your own toes so
as the people are treading around you
can kind of see the sharks are swimming
around them circling them that is
something that sharks do what they're
doing kind of while they're circling you
is not only using their ampullae blur
and zeni to figure out all right
are you like are you alive are you
giving off electrical little minute
pulses but they're also
looking at you as well that's what
they're doing with their eyes mostly is
looking at you to figure out what shape
you are and if your
food or if there's something that you've
never seen before this shark is blind so
i don't know what the heck it's doing
well i haven't seen any research being
done on what attracts a shark
more in regards to noise is it more at
the surface or more
underwater but i would think at the
surface just because you have that
splashing noise that can kind of travel
farther i think than say
underwater you don't have as much and
usually when you've got some sort of
injured animal they do kind of float up
to the surface
however because she slammed down that
noise probably did attract them to the
source of it
they saw her or sensed her there with
their superpower
blind shark powers
those are some terrifying last moments
for her um
there have been some cases especially
for surfers
that have shown a shark actually go for
like
the rib area and whatnot so that is
possible
yes i have never been bitten by a shark
but
while i was filming for shark week a few
years ago
scuba diving underwater i was actually
bitten by a 10-foot american crocodile
and i've got the scars in the story to
prove it
that actually was so deep that i could
fit my pinky up to about
there on every single one of those bite
wounds i guess you can kind of take a
little bit
of solace in that knowing that a person
who works actively with sharks
like pretty regularly has never been bit
by a shark so your chances are quite low
will two sharks fight over a person and
then
tear them in half like that probably not
very unrealistic
usually there's kind of like a hierarchy
for sharks when it comes to feeding
often times if one is kind of nibbling
the others kind of
stand back until it's engorged itself
and then they go in
in that hierarchical order they respect
their
elders and their big sharks next up
we've got deep lucy
i've never seen a setup like this for a
shark before i will say that
so we don't have any like underwater
labs like is shown here
but we do have some lab spaces that are
near water so we can actually bring
sharks into an enclosure similar to this
but
not with all the high-tech kind of gear
we do have some sharks that we keep in
enclosures
and do tests on medical tests even where
we take
blood hemoglobin and some skin tissues
our labs might not look like this but
they're still
pretty cool membrane integrity is
improving
then they're firing they're firing if
anything's going to be the most
unrealistic part of this movie it's
going to be that is scientific results
coming out that quickly
yes sharks are actually used in for
medical purposes
um not so much alzheimer's to my
knowledge
but in other ways they're more
predominantly used
it's called bioinspiration using things
that we find in nature
in other parts of our life for example
sharkskin
has actually inspired not only swimsuits
that were banned in the olympics
but also the design of airplane wings so
medically there is quite a lot out there
that sharks are starting to help with
especially because a lot of people are
curious as to
how their immune system holds up and how
powerful the immune system can be
introducing two cc's of the protein
complex
so while this scene does show sharks
it's not all about shark science it's
mostly about the medical side
and what they can use sharks for uh but
that's actually not
everything that shark scientists can do
we have kind of
our own different paths of or niches if
you will
of expertise and so for me completely
different from this
i actually look at habitat use of sharks
so figuring out why
sharks are where they are using
technology such as drones or something
that
is called grubs baited remote underwater
video cameras
essentially it's like a gopro with a
little treat bag at the end
to entice the shark to come a little bit
closer so i can get a look at it
id it and figure out if that habitat has
any significance
such as a nursery
they're like fire they're fart shark
brains are really hard to come by
because you need dead sharks for that
even though it's not my expertise
there are some people who are out there
studying these brains but
it's such a complex organ we barely
understand our brain
it's really hard to wrap our minds
around another animal's
very complex brain
um sharks they can swim actually that
kind of side to side motion so it is
very important that you tie your sharks
down properly
now are you supposed to use those kind
of ropes no there's
special ropes that we use for sharks
yeah
the the rope is not well placed
whatsoever so a lot of times for ropes
if we're gonna
loop one around the shark we also try to
loop one around one of the fins as well
so it doesn't like swim away without us
like making sure it's good to go
so the rope job here is quite
bad but sometimes we actually put covers
over the eyes
so it doesn't freak out you actually do
this with quite a lot of wild animals
so i'm a bit surprised they didn't have
it on here but also not
that surprised because it's a movie that
the guy is
in the water with him and the shark
isn't actually doing anything to the guy
can be a bit normal just because maybe
it's out of the shark's vision it
doesn't really care that much about it
but because that one guy was in front of
his vision
that's why i kind of went around and
went chomp because it's like oh i see
you
i'm unhappy i'm gonna take it out on you
yes it does look like a mako shark
congratulations
it even got the teeth right because the
teeth they almost look like needles and
they're pointed backwards because they
eat a lot of slippery fish
and so the teeth pointed backwards help
it not move around as much so
good job people do you see how there's
multiple rows
that is accurate quite a lot of shark
species do have those rows of teeth
that when one tooth in the front falls
off another
one kind of is like a conveyor belt it
comes forward and takes its place
i think on average it's like 30 000
though
uh teeth in a lifetime which is a lot
they don't get this big as you can see
it seems like it's a pretty
big enclosure that it's in and compared
to the man that you kind of see on the
edge that was in the water with this
shark
that's just not possible sharks are
pretty smart as they
as they kind of are they've been around
for millions of years
but as we've kind of said their brains
are something that we're just beginning
to understand so
trying to kind of equate smartness to a
shark is really hard to do
but we know they're really excellent
predators and what they've been doing
for a while has worked
i don't know if making them smarter
would make them more aggressive i think
it might make them more cunning hunters
though
and might make them have a little bit of
a temper and be fed up with people
poking them
next up we've got ace ventura pet
detective
that is not usually an outfit we marine
biologists where will we go to feed our
pet sharks
i've got a little snack for you
[Music]
so in that small tank probably is not
going to be able to breach
upwards kind of how you saw in the film
it might be able to like lift itself up
a bit
but not much it does need a little bit
of room to be able to propulsion itself
up to
propel itself upwards out of the water
most times when a great white shark is
reaching it usually goes like this
or like that way there's a lot more
splashing a lot more area
needed for an animal to be able to reach
definitely can see that it's a great
white shark there
would you have it as a pet no not even
aquariums are good at keeping great
white sharks in captivity
in fact monterey bay aquarium is one of
the few
that has actually kept them and for a
very short amount of time
it's very very hard to keep great white
sharks in captivity
mostly because they keep ramming into
the edges of the aquariums they
do not like captivity whatsoever just a
tidbit
while it's not illegal to own sharks in
your own personal aquarium
it's actually quite hard not only a to
get a shark
such as a great white to keep but also
some of them are protected so you can't
own them uh and it's not really the
smartest thing you want to do anyways
not only does the animal get a lesser
quality of life but you're gonna have to
pay
a lot of money to keep up with how much
a great white shark feeds
your snowflake
i've got a little snack for you one
thing that the shark
wouldn't be able to just automatically
know is that
ace venture is actually holding a fish
you need to throw a few in there
in order to get the shark's attention in
it realizing that you
actually have fish in your hands and
that you're feeding it
[Music]
no the way that you see ace venture kind
of flailing about and being held in the
jaws of this great white
shark there is no way he would be able
to walk away without
any injuries whatsoever very very
unlikely that would happen and
probably impossible don't try it at home
to prove me right or wrong please next
up we've got the shallows
so i will give props to the shadows they
have a very realistic looking great
white shark there is no denying it
tired of seeing shirts that look more
like dolphins or
as someone has like frankenstein picked
and put sharks together and made it look
like some brand new species that
i would never want to see in the dark
ocean let alone a dark alley
you didn't like that because it stings
like jellyfish
okay a great white shark would not be
just chilling in the coral reefs they're
more of
open ocean water animals so the
likelihood of them running into a coral
reef
and still sticking around in order to
get one piece of prey
very very unlikely
you see a lot of jellyfish in this movie
in this specific scene there can be
a lot of jellyfish so many in one area
actually that it's just
i mean you cannot can't even see water
it's
a bit gnarly they don't glow like this
either this like ethereal
angelic thing that's very rare
some species do glow um some of them
have like little rainbow tendrils which
is really cool like they can glow but
like that
no
yeah that's gonna hurt i've been stuck
by jellyfish before like in the face and
stuff that hurts
[Music]
okay so what you see here the shark kind
of like swimming away from the jellyfish
it hasn't been like scientifically
tested or anything but i can tell you
that sharks don't
care about jellyfish if they really want
something they will swim through the
jellyfish to get to it
they've got pretty tough skin made out
of dermal tentacles which actually
translates to
tiny teeth it helps reduce pain
as well as like drag as you can see it's
doing more pain and damage to her than
it is the shark
great white sharks believe it or not do
not like orcas
orcas are a big time predator for great
white sharks
usually the orcas actually target the
shark's liver
and sometimes it's claspers which are
the male
reproductive organs for great white
sharks once a great white shark has been
bitten by an orca
usually the great white sharks in the
surrounding area will leave for a little
bit
so become best friends with an orca
call out for them when a great white
shark is nearby and who knows maybe
they might help you out
oh yeah she's got some serious shark
burn right there
she stabbed it give her props for that
it is very hard like it is hard to get a
tag
through the door so like to the dorsal
fin of the shark let alone
stab it with like a rusty stare bit so i
will give
blake lively props for that to be able
to stab
through a shark's very tough skin uh
when she fell on the shark she's
probably going to be covered in that
shark burn too so i feel really bad for
her
she's in a world of hurt right now she's
got jellyfish thing
she's been just absolutely obliterated
by coral
now she's got shark burn she she's not
having a good job
would a sheriff jump up to get a prey
item
like that once it's on some sort of like
structure or whatever
possibly i've never seen it happen none
of my colleagues have ever seen it
happen so
i want to say very unlikely that this
scenario here is realistic
great white sharks are cosmopolitan
animals that means you see them in all
sorts of oceans of all of our oceans
really
would they be this close to shore
possibly uh especially if there's a dead
whale carcass and this is actually
something that can happen yes
would it stick around for tons and tons
of time
probably not and this has happened
before in like hawaii and other pacific
islands
and it does attract sharks to come
closer and usually
officials do say stay away from the dead
whale and the surrounding area
because it does attract sharks i haven't
heard of anyone being
bitten by a shark when there was a whale
carcass
in the area but i think that's because
most people have
common enough sense to not be in the
water
with something that is essentially
ringing a big dinner bell
sharks are definitely not vindictive as
it has been portrayed in this movie
um they don't hold a grudge promise
as you can see the portrayal of sharks
and movies isn't always the best
they need a little bit of a pr manager
because even though they're portrayed as
these scary monsters
that's not actually the truth you don't
have to worry about an ocean filled with
sharks
instead you should be worried about an
ocean without them
thanks so much for watching these clips
with me i'll see you next time